[Music]
Kevin welcome to the show sorry Thank
You Man thanks for having me and I
thought we would start with a quote from
a mutual friend I won't mention his name
unless you want to mention it but I
asked him about you and he said you were
the person he would most like to be like
Wow coming from him that is very strong
praise he knows a lot of people and he
suggested that I learn more about your
mother but I I have done a whole lot of
homework and I feel like she was a very
powerful influence in your life and I'm
going to just hear you describe your
mother and your relationship with her if
we could cool cool who's the friend
right do I get to know who the front
mother knows is Neal oh okay yes ah my
mother
I mean God what do you want me to we
want me to start about my mom I mean
that's my that's my reason for the way
that I move at the lows that I move and
how I move you know um I think I could
just sum it up for you in like a nice
nutshell to where it's not it's not as
long as run on sentence that you've ever
heard just one of the most determined
and strong-willed individuals to ever
walk the earth and she was someone that
just wanted to always improve I wasn't
content with just being complacent in a
position because this is the position
that I'm giving her that I have I was
always searching for the next step so
whether it was an education whether it
was you know in health whether it was
and family it was always trying to
figure out how to improve when most
would be okay with just being okay you
know we didn't live a lavish lifestyle
we didn't come from money
you know we
we were we were we were we were we were
poor
you know we we had enough to eat and she
put clothes on my back
um but you know that's that's about it
we didn't we didn't we didn't live an
astronomical life you know I'm the extra
money that she did have she poured into
extracurricular activities for me so I
probably already was her kids and and it
showed you know where some mistakes with
me fixes were immediately figured out
and implemented on the next child so
it's a it's woman that I have so much
respect for and admire but um she's
basically the definition of my mindset
it comes from I and I was spending a lot
of time exploring your mindset I've
followed you for a long time but I
wanted to dig into your books and your
writing obviously a lot of what you've
done in terms of interviews and in the
back of your book I can't make this up
subtitle life lessons there's a
beautiful little chapter called the
blueprint and I want to just read a
paragraph from that and give people the
taste because I think it speaks to what
we're discussing it says life is like a
pack of cards there are 52 cards in the
deck but only four of them are aces the
goal of life is to make your way through
a crowded deck where the odds are
stacked against you and draw an ace
looking back over decades covered in
this book I've picked out eight
qualities that put me in a position to
draw aces these characteristics won't
work alone like a recipe they only
create success when combined together in
just the right amount so I'm just gonna
list them real quick and then I want to
dig into one you have persistence
patience class commitment learning
passion centered competitiveness
positivity and discomfort I want to talk
about positivity or hear you talk about
positivity because for instance I was I
was reading a piece in variety that
seemed to me to indicate that you are a
master of managing energy and avoiding
energy leaks and for instance the
decision to allow your children to get
to know you're their grandfather your
father
the quote that stuck out to me was it
takes too much time and energy to keep
hate alive and for those people who
don't know I'm and your father was an
addict you've you've spoken about him
publicly before a contentious
relationship how have you developed that
positivity was that mostly from your mom
how do you think about that well when
you when you come from the bottom yeah
and you work your way up to when you
work your way up to the place that some
people refer to as the top I mean what
do I have to be angry about what do I
have to really [ __ ] and complain about
and heartburn you know like I I really
do come from nothing I'm I'm a part of a
very small percentage so in
understanding that knowing that the
things that are supposed to act as
triggers the things that are supposed to
be life-changing threatening you know
altering are just lessons
it's just education it's it's stories
for lack of a better word you know you
got an amazing story under your belt and
I don't choose to stay in one particular
paragraph of my story it's a long story
and you know the life is as long as of
course we are all given the chance for
it to be because that's something that
we have no control we only tried to
enhance the opportunity of longevity or
success we don't have no control you
walk outside something could happen boom
and that's it so I just have a realistic
approach and understanding to that I
come from nothing I got something I'm
appreciative of my something I don't
look at this something as if I'm
supposed to have it because that's not
how it works
I'm very fortunately blessed to it
could all go away if it didn't I had to
start all over again that's life
I don't harp on it I don't [ __ ] you
complain about the things that I can't
change and the things that you can
change why spend time bitching if you're
gonna change it yeah you know I mean so
when you when you look at for example
relationship with me and my father did
my father [ __ ]
yeah my father get himself clean and
straight yeah does my father feel bad
about some of the stuff that he did yeah
could you still be angry at the lack of
parenting that was done or the time that
was spent yeah but why because it
doesn't change it it doesn't change
anything that happened it doesn't it
doesn't make it right you know I mean
like you don't that that anger that
you're that you're giving off in today
it's not going to change these things so
that's energy that I feel like I can put
into something else that's energy that I
feel like I can get a lot more use out
of that energy that would have been
negative I find a way to say you know
what I do forgive you and I mean that
and they're like now hopefully it's
better for us if it's not I know that
it's not because of me I don't like
putting myself in a position to easily
be affected you know I think life is too
short it's too short
and if you just spend time being
affected all the [ __ ] time those are
tough days men if you're bothered all
the time there's a lot of [ __ ] to be
back what about the day you can be
bothered a lot of [ __ ] if you're the
person that's really bothered then how
how pleasant are you to be around yeah
if there's just so much anger and and so
much negative energy
I I just choose the opposite direct and
approach and I mean
and it made me perfect I'm nowhere near
perfect
I didn't [ __ ] up but I did stupid [ __ ]
and I'm apologizing if I can be you know
those apologies can be accepted then
great it's fantastic if they can't well
I can't do anything about that I can't
put any more energy into the things that
I've tried to do or make right if you
choose to still feel a certain way
god bless you I'm gonna keep living
that's my attitude and it seems like
you've practiced this consistently over
time and then when you run into
something like the catastrophic car
accident you had not terribly long ago
did you speak to not being able to put
on your socks and what your self-talk
was like I mean what are you saying to
yourself in your own head when you're
experiencing something like that once
you truly realize that you're not in
control like right now I said that to
you that's because I really understand
that but there was a moment where I love
Saturday ltu kind of feel like you are
you're not a control but you kind of
feel like you are I can make this happen
I'll do this I'll get this easy I'll get
it done I got it I'll do it
I'm at it I'm work hard I'm gonna do it
i-i-i-i and you get lost in it you know
you really do get lost in that and for
me that car today was much more than any
and everybody can see for me that car
accident it was a reason to sit down and
really process what's around me and I
would surround me the things that only
matter and that was my my wife and my
kids you know all the things that I put
the significant value and tremendous
amount of uh I'm gonna call them you put
the things that come with success on a
pedestal for a minute the things that
you feel you need and
that you feel you have to have right um
but when life hits you with a real
curveball and you're in that room with
four walls
none of that stuff that she thought was
important or that he thought you needed
is ever bought up in conversation when
it comes to life when it comes to health
when it comes to like you know an
emotional support none of its
materialistic it's all person-to-person
and when it was my wife and my brother
and my kids and we were just in his
hospital room that gave me a different
different look
and insight into life so it made me
shoulder shrug negative [ __ ] even more I
already had no tolerance or patience for
negativity I already was a god never
feed it into to the world of nonsense
and I something I pride myself for but
then after this it was even more Oh time
to be upset even if I am upset I'm gonna
figure out what I can do to make this
better I don't have time to do that it's
not it's not valuable mm-hmm one of the
things that most fascinates me about you
and this is shown up over and over again
and in what I've read in preparation for
there's also what I see is that you have
say is one of the aces so to speak you
have discomfort right never being
complacent if you want to get far in
life you never get too comfortable don't
stop don't rest don't be satisfied so
you know I've heard that when when you
hit these various pinnacles of success
in different areas that one of the first
questions you ask is okay what's next
where do we go from here and and yet for
instance Neil told me that I asked him I
said D do you think that he is genuinely
happy and he said he is I go from what I
can tell he's a genuinely happy guy and
in my experience of interviewing high
performers those two don't always go
together you find people who are never
are able to appreciate what's in front
of them or to rest for a moment because
they're constantly focused on what's in
the future what's next how do you
combine those in the sense of
appreciating what you have but still
deliberately building in discomfort or
not getting too comfortable and looking
forward how do you think about that well
you got BA in AAA
right so you got before accident after
accident mm-hmm before accident that
engine that engine ran that engine is
still running I can't set up here and
act as if it's not I'm just an ambitious
person and I'm in love I'm in love with
understanding the definition of history
right what fascinates me is when you
watch something from the past that's
attached to an individual or a person
and a monumental moment in history
that's fascinating this man walked on
money on this date such a sesh regular
guy one bit of snot was the first man to
ever walk on the moon and four years
after his life is over
it's a discussion it's a discussion it's
information that people need to know
that's fascinating to me right now we're
in a pandemic our world has been hit
with a catastrophic stomach punch that's
put us all in a position where the
economy is dropped and we have been put
on quarantine huh and we're at home for
how long and now it's gonna be this long
this is history this moment in time will
be talked about in 30 to 40 years as one
of the worst things to hit the globe
when coded and X Y & Z and check its
history so my hard work
in my craft and my hard work is from me
playing the game in my head of are you
going to be a conversation attached to
history how long will the work that you
put in be a discussion our people on a
one day look back and say things about
the things that you did and if they do
what would it be I like not knowing it
but I like knowing that I put a lot of
[ __ ] in that conversation I like knowing
that you're gonna have a lot of [ __ ] to
talk about whether you like it or not
because I'm in love with just doing that
I'm in love with the resume I'm in love
with the boxes that can be checked off
I'm in love with the the thought of
success and more importantly the benefit
that comes from hard work I'm in love
with being a testament to the
conversation has preached to so many
that son don't necessarily know of his
truth I'm a product of truth I'm a
product of hard work pays off I like
that I like the fact that that was
instilled in me and I didn't get it but
now I do get it and it's thank you mine
at the highest level I like the fact
that my kids get to see me operate and
then I get to talk and communicate with
them and whether they do it like I do or
not it's embedded in them it'll kick in
somewhere in something it'll kick in
whether they like it or not it's
embedded in you so my joy definitely
comes from being able to see the
benefits of my work and being able to
create a story that can possibly be
talked about years after I'm here that's
a that's for me that's a happy place and
if and when I decide to to not do it
anymore
I'm happy with
after my accident it did make me say
let's be conscious of your family let's
make sure that we put the time and
energy into this that matches the time
and energy that I'm putting into that
this should never outweigh that and
there was a moment where I was guilty of
that and the accident made me realize
that so Kevin you make sure that if you
go on out of the thousand percent over
here you don't come back at nine hundred
you better match that thousand on both
sides and that's where I'm much more
conscious I've always been you know a
great family guy a great dad - my
[ __ ] bumps in the road I'm just
stupidity I'm a good day that's not
gonna be compromised never never gonna
[ __ ] economize it seems like you have
done a excellent consistent job of
cultivating your physical vehicle for
giving a hundred percent in many areas
of your life has that always been the
case when did that start for you uh I
would say I would say for me I don't
understand how you do something halfway
I did that through high school and doing
that I saw the I saw the instant
consequence you know there was a moment
where after high school where my friends
went on and they started going to
college and I was the guy who didn't
even know to reapply
I didn't know what I was applying to
college what a job I thought it was
playing all this time were y'all gone
what was a joke to me was never a joke
to anybody else I was the only one that
the joke was being played to on so what
I thought we were hooking or cutting
class well I thought we all weren't
going work I thought we all were or
getting by in just [ __ ] off
opportunities oh it's just me Oh y'all
been doing your work this whole time oh
[ __ ] huh Wow University of University of
University
I was the only jackass I was going to
Community College that's not to take a
shot anybody was going to Community
College because those colleges are
available for a reason I was doing
jackass and didn't have a plan because I
thought that was the cool thing to do so
I saw it not working hard got me I
didn't take my SAT I did an advocate dad
but going down and guessing at it
because I thought that's what we all
were doing because we were hooking in
class to go I was the only [ __ ] then
did it the other way so that joke was on
me that to me that was an eye-opener man
well if I'm gonna do something I should
never do a half way and that means that
if I didn't want to do it that way
couldn't do it and I'm not gonna do it
to show what I can do it the best my
visit then why am i doing it if you
asked me to come work out what you're
not come work out and I bought you to
work out while I'm gonna work out if you
ask me to come see a movie and I go to
sleep and as soon as I get in there well
why don't I go to the movie why didn't I
just say I want to stay home if you ask
me to go and get up early with you so we
can go look at these these apartments or
our housing complexes and I get down
there and it's got a negative attitude
why the [ __ ] did I go what I've learned
and how I operate is that you're in so
much control of yourself that it's
ridiculous and sometimes it's easy to
put out excuses for yourself that make
sense to you we all know the [ __ ]
truth we all know if we're giving a
hundred percent of every night we all
know you tell me go outside and pick up
the dog [ __ ] my wife tell me every
morning I don't want to go out there and
pick the dog [ __ ] but I get up and do it
if I go out there and I take two steps
and I'm like minutes to early I'll do
this [ __ ] later then that means that I'm
[ __ ] I'm I'm already he compromising
an action that I said I was going to do
that I'm not if I say I want to do
something I'm gonna do it if I don't say
it don't expect
different me I never put my foot in my
mouth well why do you expect me to go
through that I never said I would do
that that's the one power that I have
that's the one thing that can never be
taken from me what I say I'm going to do
I do and if I do do something that puts
me in a position to be scolded because
my actions weren't correct then I gotta
stand up and I gotta say that too
hey I said I was gonna do XYZ I didn't
do it I gotta wear that hat hit me with
the stupid stick at a dummy hat scold me
whatever you gotta do
I [ __ ] up I out loud said that I would
do and I did it so that I'm wrong that's
the difference that's what I'm okay with
I'm okay with standing and [ __ ]
smelling it if I have to I try my best
to avoid it but I'm not perfect
so there's ever a moment where that
happens and it has to happen though I
morning but as I've gotten older my
words become more of my bond take care
of me I want you to talk to these kids
man look there's a group of kids Hey I
can't do that I'm not because of the
kids
I'm tired it's fine another time where I
can there's a time back in the day camp
atop said yeah yeah I figure you can't
get me on the phone well why don't I say
I could do it I've learned from that I
don't I don't play those games so if I
say you're gonna get me you're gonna get
100% of me and I don't feel like I can
then I'm not gonna say do you have do
you have other ways of saying no that
you uses sort of default language or
anything like that because people see
what you do right you mean you have so
much in the air and you're getting so
much done but they they don't see the
thousands of things that you say no to
right I just I can say right now I am I
am so
right now I'm so honest that it is it's
so it's ridiculous right like right now
I am I am no carries it absolutely not
no forty years old what I got time to be
around Bush for know why I just don't
want to do that I don't want to do that
I shouldn't have to explain why I want
to do something I shouldn't have to
explain that's it that's the thing that
people have to overcome there's a
portion of life that you go through
where you feel guilty for saying that
you don't want to do certain things
that's not fair because when you do want
to do things the celebrations and as
happy times but you're allowed to not
want to do
you're allowed the option to say no you
say no for things that work for you then
good for you you can be saying no to
opportunity for all I know you're
allowed the option to say no into not
what to participate or not want to do
that's your choice
and anything I know that and I'll make
sure that I use my nose wisely there's a
lot of yeses so and there isn't no
understand that for example I love my
fans I love my fans take pictures of
fans all the time go back and pull for
fans all the time make myself available
before red carpets after carpets
movie premieres not movie premieres I'm
out and about seeing them stopped all
pictures videos but if I'm with my kids
no Kevin Keith I said no I shouldn't
have to explain to you I'm with my
family I shouldn't have to do that I'm
entitled to know that's why you got two
options you got yes or no you thought
maybe in there that's your choice huh is
it yes or no so as you get older you
start to see that a little more clear
and I joke around about it but it's so
true you ever notice how die
correct and I'm as old people are yep
for sure have you ever noticed the old
person does not waste to him No
yeah do it no get your answer buddy
whatever it is it's it's it's direct
because they don't have the time they
don't have the time to to play those
games I don't either
I don't I don't play those games anymore
one thing that you seem very good at is
long-term investments and thinking and
what I give a few examples of that so if
you if you look at the path of Kevin
which which I've done to get ready for
this conversation and I noticed these
seemingly little things like for
instance you go from Community College
to as I understand it selling shoes open
mikes eventually you're you're hitting
the road and touring gathering email
addresses right you have people putting
cards on tables you're sowing the seeds
of tremendous things later and what I'd
love to hear you maybe discuss a little
bit is how do you choose your
opportunities so that there steps up and
not steps sideways or steps backwards
because you have a lot thrown at you how
do you think about that strategically or
how do you think about it at all well I
think when you're talking about
opportunities in general the the best
part about opportunities are figuring
out what makes them an amazing
opportunity for you right and you know I
think you're extremely lucky if you're
doing something you love you know if
you're doing something that may not
necessarily be your passion but it's a
job the trick is to find out how to make
this thing become a bigger thing for you
so that you're able to go and do what
you want to do how do we use the things
in life that are thrown as step stones
or baby pathways to the to the ultimate
road right um so for me I have a great
my
vision is ridiculous so if life was like
if you could compare it to let's call it
let's call like an MD 500 you know when
these guys in race cars whenever racing
in cars they're never looking right in
front of them they're they're way up in
the road before they make it time
they're looking at the time after that
time to decide how to handle this turn
so that we're gonna come out that time
they're on a straightaway already that's
a how they're gonna come out you have to
have vision that's in front that's at
least set as a goal as a destination of
where you're trying to get and once you
get there you can reassess the
opportunities that I have were ones that
were wanted back when I want to be a
stand-up comedian now I understand a
comedian I want to make sure that I'm
telling jokes
that can allow me to travel to globe one
day I want to make everybody laugh if I
can make everybody laugh I would travel
the globe if I get the opportunity to
travel the globe that gives me the
opportunity to start on that journey of
making the world laugh opportunity one
is getting to a position to perform
outside of the US that would be massive
let me give what's my first opportunity
doing something that's considered
international what is it where does it
where does this exist my first time
going to Canada I didn't know what to
expect
cuz I'm a guy from North Philadelphia
what language do they speak what's gonna
happen when I'm here I just landed in
[ __ ] Canada oh my god
hi how are you I'm looking for this
hotel why are you yelling sir okay whoa
I'll perform a can of people that is it
like this everywhere I go to London holy
[ __ ] I'm in London for the first time oh
my god
people speak English what if I can make
I'm making people laugh in London oh my
god the opportunity that I was talking
about is now happening it's a reality
man what doors can comedy open up
what if comedy got me to acting Eddie
Murphy was a comedian he started acting
how do you do it what if I got into me
oh my god it got me the opportunity to
act oh my god nothing what if I can
figure out an opportunity to create oh
my god created showed me that you can
write oh my god what is writing creates
more opportunities holy [ __ ] that's how
you produce now I'm producing oh my god
what if I can dive right oh [ __ ]
then you look all the way back behind
you it all started off with the goal
doing comedy mm-hmm but the
opportunities kept getting bigger
because you kept looking past the first
opportunity yet what the what-if was
that doesn't mean that you're not
respecting the things you're doing it
just means that you're realizing why you
should do this well that's what I do so
my vision is is ridiculous yeah I'm
always down the street no matter what
have you ever played Monopoly and
there's a person to play with and it'll
get like you know they'll they'll eat
the worst property on the game and
people go a lot to [ __ ] you buy a net
you got Baltic Evan Mediterranean yeah I
did it's the cheapest one but I'm gonna
put all of my houses and then flip those
in the hotels and it's cheaper I now
have money left and hopefully for making
money on this I can gonna get some of
the nicer stuff I can go and get the
maybe the boardwalks or maybe the
mentors or
you know maybe maybe some of the other
more expensive but I want to get my
money right first cuz I'm have enough
meeting other people to go riding or Bob
or walk and then they're stuck with $200
or $300 after and it's trying to figure
out how to get houses but it can't
really afford the thing they bought cuz
they don't have a plan there's other
people that put a plan together that
they're trying to execute that can get
them to the place that they want to be
I'm the guy with a plan and whether I
get there and I am executing something
that I'm vetting out yeah you know name
its I'm getting it out and I'm trying my
best to get there by checking all these
boxes and building an amazing team
around me a people had a morning
qualified to help me on this journey so
it doesn't become a Kevin did a thing it
becomes a we did a thing and then before
you know you change lives and now you're
able to have a major impact not just
with laughs they're not just by
providing content but now you're
providing jobs opportunities now you're
providing you know many providing dreams
hope there's a it's a bigger story to it
it's a bigger story is a bigger
understanding so I definitely want to
talk about stories and storytelling but
before we get there we were talking you
were talking about this macro planning
vetting and looking at opportunities I'd
love to look at the micro for a second
what what does say the first 90 minutes
of your day to look like are there any
components or routines that are
particularly important to you
in the first hour two of your minutes of
my day yeah our two if there's anything
that is a constant for you there's no I
mean the one thing that never changes is
my marker up six of me most sensors in
record time to working on 7:00 a.m.
every day but before this if I'm like I
wanna work in I'm up it five you know in
the gym and very consistent about that I
don't I don't I don't sway with that you
know it's how I start any and every day
and I'm just heavily into taking care of
me
um got a lot of people that depend on me
a lot of people that that that I feel
need me and also that I need in return
um but I can't be the best version of
myself if I'm not taking care of myself
what it what are some of the in your
mind because you've exercised a long
time and very consistently so you have
had a chance to test a lot what are some
of them the best bang for the buck
exercises if you could only kind of take
a handful with you or do any come to
mind
nothing B's push-ups this is I don't
care whether you got a gym on now that's
the core it can't be there ever with
stories and storytelling what strikes me
is you're a student of history you're
looking at what can become stories that
are told decades maybe a hundred years
after they happen and you are in some
respects it strikes me making your mark
with an incredible gift and hones talent
of storytelling when I when I watch you
perform mm-hmm what makes a good
storyteller there any particular people
you consider good storytellers I mean
whether it's the I know you've cited the
Bible the there is there certain stories
that are more compelling than others and
certain storytellers are there any
storytellers who stand out to you I mean
- what what's going on in the personal
life of this individual you know Cosby
is one of the probably one of the best
storytellers within a profession of
comedy I like I said making sure that
it's separate from of course you know
this stuff
ah Eddie Murphy amazing storyteller Dave
Chappelle an amazing storyteller I mean
you're looking at people to have very
unique styles and approaches to the
craft of storytelling those are my
favorites and I'm gonna tell you who
else is one of the best I was on the
best that storyteller Bernie Mac Bernie
back Bernie Mac Bernie Mac
could tell a story and I mean that you
know I I love it I love the idea of
telling a story I love the idea of you
know grabbing someone's attention and
holding that attention and a person
going on levels with you until the end
and at the end of it getting an amazing
payoff to where it's like oh my god
didn't even see that coming that's crazy
like hey there's something special about
that I've always been a fan of it you
know and it's a it's a it's a craft and
a talent that I tried my best to hone
and work on I want to talk about the
decision so this is inaudible original
the decision and the subtitle is
overcoming today's BS for tomorrow
success it seems like this had been in
the works for a very long time and then
the launch got accelerated because there
are certain things that you can't do
right now with cognitive quarantine but
there are things that you can do like
utilize audio could you speak to why you
decided to push this forward now and why
you did it in the first place well I
said so basically you know right now I
think the crazy thing with in the times
that shows you're realizing the need
behind content you know like you you see
what people gravitate towards when times
are tough like you know you there's an
escape that comes with good content
you're able to get lost in something
good like I remember when his first hit
and
ozark and came over and the season was
available I was like oh Ozark and I sat
and I watched o's are in for that time I
just enjoyed a good show a good show was
enough it was it was enough for me and
it motivated me after watching and I was
like
get up and I gotta write kind of right I
gotta create I got it right and watching
that shit'll made me do that now of
course this is my profession this is
what I do so it's where I can grab
energy from but there's content all
around that can amplify a person's mood
there's different types of content
that's good for whomever you don't mean
is it's it's a lot that you can go out
and grab or read or see that just it's
just a lot so I told my team I was like
this is this is a perfect time just for
me to release the decision and the
reason why is because it's not just
informative but it's mental fitness and
and when when our mental is getting
tugged on just having information can be
key just information my way of thinking
is in the right way
everybody Ellen I don't claim that I
don't stand on that it's not my way or
the highway
I'm just giving you an option I'm just
sharing wholeheartedly what has helped
me in life and what has helped get me to
this place and how my thinking and
thought process had played a major part
and I want to give you guys this
information you may gravitate towards it
you may not but I'm gonna give it to you
in a way that nobody else can I'm giving
it to you a personality I'm giving it to
you with real-life situations attached
that you can look up and see and I'm
giving it to you from a guy's
perspective that has results so as not
as if there aren't any results in my way
of thinking and in my way of decision
making you see what the results are
which is why I feel like they're for
nation's value you know guys I like this
there's chapters on positivity there's
chapters on negativity there's chapters
on cowboying up there's chapters on
shoulder shrugging there's chapters on
things that we overlook that are so
small that I've made big you know a
shoulder shrug shoulder shrug is a
[ __ ] man the ability to shrug
your shoulders
it can mean so many things shrugging
your shoulders can mean I don't care you
mean I don't know what you mean oh well
it is what it is that ability to
shoulder shrug that's a major that's a
major thing because that's also the
ability to move on ones that's also the
ability to go right well I guess I gotta
keep going a shoulder shrug that's what
it is it can be taken as nonchalant that
you'd be taking his passive you can be
taken to so many different things but
not sounds out of the ten after shoulder
shrug you're gonna keep going yeah and
these are the things not broken down in
this audible original if it's me giving
you just a different way of seeing
things a different insight and your
memoir I mean if we describe it as that
I I can't make this up was extremely
popular on audio and is is the way to
think about this new audible original I
mean I think the subtitle describes it
well overcoming today's BS for tomorrow
success a more prescriptive description
of your kind of tools and principles
it's sort of a distilled collection of
your tools and tactics is that one way
to think about it if they're if people
are wondering how it contrasts to I
can't make this up I can say for me what
I what I really really love is when you
look at my my first book life lessons
right I really broke down my life and
great detail that I just gave the
stories of where I've come from and how
I got to here
and major success people loved it they
loved the honesty that came with it and
it just loved the stories they loved
hearing about my father my mother my
brother they just loved the overall
story in this one I want to go step
further because what I what I realized
was are you privy to a lot of
information and I'm privy to a lot of
different environments and I've been a
sponge and I've soaked up so much
information outside of my wife and kids
and some of my closest friends am I am I
just taking this information with me
what I found is for me right now if I
were just to go and take all the
information that I had and just keep it
and put in my pocket
what I selfish cuz extremely [ __ ]
selfish to not share to not share any of
this and look at it's very selfish on my
part so I'll say I want to share I want
to give information but this information
is to really help you understand how to
maneuver and the BS that we all go
through and this people have really
struggled with a lot of the BS that we
go through you know there's a there's a
real struggle that comes with thought
process with decision-making with do I
make it right do I make it left there's
a real struggle that goes with that and
it just comes from lack of knowledge or
from thinking it you're alone and then
nobody else's the way you are things
like you think I mean I can put it on a
list of things when you're able to open
up and talk about things that most
people don't
in such an honest way it acts as a bone
you know there's there's a piece in
there while I'm talking about social
media and how social media has been such
a gift and a curse I've been on the side
of the gift I've been on the side of the
gift it allowed me to connect and touch
base with my fans in order that never
thought that I will be able to and then
there's this dark side to her that's
reared its head
and that dark side just seems like it's
negative but it only seems that way
because there's something in us as
people to be attracted to the negative
we're attracted to [ __ ] for some
reason if there's a story about a man
that saved a kid and at the same time a
story gets posted about a woman that cut
our husband's dick off you're gonna
forget about the man to save the kid
everybody's running to the story about
the woman that cut her husband's dick
off nobody can answer that question of
why you can't tell me why but it's true
it's what we gravitate towards it's
people so that's why the internet seems
like a hub for negativity the news is on
every night there's always a good story
on the news but you can't tell me what
it is but you can tell me about all the
people that got shot you tell me about
the store to get robbed you can't tell
me the good story
you can't highlight the things that good
is because the volume is time down and
that's because we choose not to turn it
up so it's not until you realize that
hey you know what I'm looking at this
thing man there's a lot of negative
comments on here well how many other
positive ones did you actually see right
did you give that the same attention
these are things that I'm given and then
all go back to the decisions there's a
decision that I'm making to speak on or
to amplify what can be perceived as
[ __ ] or negativity I'm making the
decision not
give the same energy and effort to the
thing a positive is there but I'm making
a decision to not realize it or see it
I have tons times of this and it's
audible original mm-hmm
cowboying up you make the decision to
sit and [ __ ] about what you can't
change you talked about earlier that's a
decision or you can make the decision to
say you know what I'm a cowboy up cowboy
up as a time some time that anybody can
use and cowboy up just means I'm a strap
on my boots I'm gonna get back to work
that's it that work can mean anything in
keening life it can mean family it could
mean you know humanitarian work whatever
that thing is I'm not gonna let the
problems weigh me down to where I
stopped doing what I'm supposed to do
I'm gonna make the decision to continue
I keep going on the decision as you
mentioned audible original yes
releasing May 21st overcoming today's BS
for tomorrow's success I've been
fascinated in the process of getting to
know you through research for this
conversation and I'm excited to see it
come out and listen to it I suppose more
accurately and people can find you of
course you're not hard to find on
Instagram at Kevin Hart for real the
number four on Facebook that's heart
Kevin and then on Twitter same as
Instagram at Kevin Hart for real
Kevin is there anything else you would
like to share before we before we wrap
up any any words of wisdom favorite
quotes things you live your life by
anything else um you know what I'll say
right now I think the the biggest and
best thing is just to get people to
understand that you know look these
times are extremely tough for first of
all but there's always sunshine behind
the cloud this is just a very dark cloud
we'll get through it we'll get
love it and you know when we do let's be
better than we were when we went in you
know and what uh what I think is really
dope that I was able to see that I was
able to hold on to and gravitate towards
is how so much money has been raised to
solve and help for world hunger but it
took a pandemic and it shouldn't have to
be because of a pandemic that we're all
conscience of the needs of others it's
something that should be more of a
priority and when you see these hundreds
of millions of dollars that have been
raised you know within the two-month
period of time you know just kind of
raises the question of what why is this
so far fueling in between yeah shouldn't
take a pandemic to make us all aware
let's open our eyes and start to just
once again look beneath the debris and
let's let's get to these other real
things that come out of this that we can
hold on to and make other people be
responsible for in the future
you know think about some you know what
somebody said that really made me go wow
we're solving world hunger and you know
where the hundreds of millions of
dollars but for Flint Michigan clean
water has been a problem for how many
years and that's how many million dollar
fix time to cowboy up yeah man this has
been a great conversation do great
conversation yeah thanks so much and
I'll I'll certainly put all these links
also in the show notes for people at
teamed-up log forward slash podcast and
Kevin real pleasure to connect thanks
I'm taking the time I mean thank you I
appreciate you yeah you too my man I'm
safe bye-bye
you